Okay, so. We've got this new technique for that,
that we just learned. About a hash thing. So we're
going to use this and our cookie to prevent people from
cheating. Remember we had that example where it, it kept
a count. And we want to use hashing to
verify on, if that count is valid And the algorithm's
going to look something like this. So instead of just saying
set cookie visits equal five, which an, anybody can edit,
we're going to add a hash to this. So we're going to
send something like this instead. Set cookie equals five. We're going to
add something on the end of this. So we'll add
a comma, and then we're going to add a hash of the
value here five. So that, a would be cheater can't
forge a cookie without knowing what hashing algorithm we used. So
we sent this cookie with five followed by, you know, our
hex string, you know, abc one, two three, it'll be whatever
the output of our hash was. When we receive this
cookie from the browser, we'll receive this five, you know, followed
by our hash, what we're going to do is we're going to break
this apart into two pieces. You know this will be like
our our value and this will be our hash. We're
going to hash this value and check to see check to
see if it equals this hash and if it does, we
know this value hasn't been tampered with and if it doesn't,
we know the cookie's invalid and we can throw it out. So our codes going
to look something like this. We we split apart the cookie value, based on this
comma into two parts, value and and hash and then we rehash the value and
if it matches the one we sent we know that our cookie hasn't be tampered with.